- Tell you what, with this online draft, man.
DEREK, CAN YOU MAKE THE INTERNET EASIER, MAN?
- That’s why I moved in next door, Coach!
OK, so the problem is that you were using the computer
like a whiteboard.
- OK, I tell ya what, how do I draft another QB?
- Oh…
- Welcome to this year’s draft—
- ARE WE DOING THIS OR NOT?!
- I GOT HERE BEFORE MCVAY
- HEY GUYS I’M BACK.
- Oh, I can finally mute my employees.
Now we’ve created DIGITAL RECREATIONS so that players can still hug me.
- I love you, football daddy.
- [Computerized voices] BOOO! GOODELL SUCKS.
- What the hell? I thought we programmed out the boos...
All right, first pick is the Bengals. You’re on the clock, Zac Taylor.
- Who?
- Return of the Zac, y'all! With my first pick, I’m obviously taking…
[Computerized voice] UNIVERSITY OF GEORGIA KICKER RODRIGO BLANKENSHIP.
No! I didn’t say that! I’ve been Zac Hacked!
- We’ve been hacked.
Do you want to play…
OH, HELL YEAH, I LOVE MIND GAMES.
- No one can make us make terrible picks!
[Computerized voice] WE DRAFT JORDAN LOVE AT 2.
- [Roger Goodell:] Was he hacked?
- [Mike McCarthy:] Yeah, I don't know.
- [Doug Pederson:] Yeah, I can totally see them doing that.
- NO, I WAS HACKED! WE HAVE A GOOD CULTURE NOW, REMEMBER?
- AHHHHH!
- This is an opportunity. The Lions draft Ohio State’s...
[Computerized voice] URBAN MEYER
Oh no.
- He’s making me draft Daniel Jones again.
- The hacker's just telling me to just do whatever I was planning on doing.
- OK, the Dolphins draft…
[Computerized voice] Justin Herbert. It’s just not possible to evaluate Tua’s ankle right now.
- Let’s handle this hacker the way I dealt with Cody Parkey: publicly and emotionally.
First person to toss me my discipline bat gets to be Bears QB.
- Throwing things from six feet away? You’re going down, Foles!
- I think I’ve had a weird career.
- Think: Who is the one person that got beef with everybody?
- Nope, not me. Y'all take care now.
- Probably Jameis... Better call him.
- Hey, coaches, I just want you to know I’ve been grinding and
working real hard and AHHHHH—
- Hey, Jameis just accidentally threw me his phone. I don’t think it’s him.
- Patriots...traded up.
- Wish I knew how to use computers. Oh well. We’ll take Tua. Bye.
- You don’t think…Belichick was the hacker?
- No, there’s no way he’d take advantage of a unique situation better than any of us.
- I’m watching your Zoom calls too.
- OK, let’s cut to our joint coverage of the draft!
- I don't know if I'd draft Tua.
- I just think that—
- You gotta go D-line here
- No you go.
- No, you go.